I think if someone threw something at me
I would like I've been very composed of
trying to stay like like teach myself to
not be mad at things but someone threw
something at me I think there's like
some latent switch in me that would be
like
[Music]
all right this is not gonna be a smart
article by any means what do you mean
well is the rest were smart that's what
he means I just think I just for some
reason this just hits something with me
that I just appreciate and uh this is
anyone it's I don't even [ __ ] I
almost wanted to cancel if I said [ __ ]
it Harry Styles mid concert somebody
just threw a bottle at it and hit him in
the nuts that's sick nice
why would they do that
[Applause]
that's so funny I didn't even see it
[Music]
[Applause]
that's classic bro
[Applause]
his reaction's the best
he's just like that for sure that it
just looks like such a British reaction
oh oh looks like a very human reaction
dude you got to put sound effects on
that that just made me it just made me
think like during any of your time
whether you were doing stand up or
you're dancing or you're in the middle
of a grapple I don't know has anything
like this ever happened in the middle of
the crap girls don't look at me some
[ __ ] has that ever happened no that
hasn't happened to me yet no there's a
comedian what's her I forget her name
but she was doing stand-up and someone
threw a a can of beer at her yeah I saw
that and Whitney coming no no it was
like what's her name the New York Comic
yeah she was talking about like Trump
and Biden or something right and then
some Trump supporter through a [ __ ]
can of beer or something at her she
picked it up and just drank it yeah like
a hero yeah yeah like a legend Stone
Cold I've seen it happen there's a clip
of Bill Burr doing stand up too he's
like at a corporate gig and someone
throws it he's he's like just talk he's
already feuding with audience and
someone throws it like a powdered donut
at him and it bounces off of him he's
like I don't give a [ __ ] because you
guys dream about being [ __ ]
businessmen you [ __ ] quitters and he
just goes dude it's amazing but it just
bounces off he's like I don't give a
[ __ ] dude [ __ ] you it's amazing donut
it's like ever since that one Philly
show where you did that Infamous rant
people wanted him to do that in their
cities I guess I don't know he seemed
like they were kind of already like
going at it I don't know they didn't
seem happy to have him talking [ __ ] to
him you know I think if someone threw
something at me I would like I've been
very composed of trying to have stayed
like like teach myself to not be mad at
things but someone threw something at me
I think there's like some light and
switch in me that would be like
you know but something like if someone
threw something at me on stage I would
be I think I hope that it's dead in
there but I think there's some rage that
would turn on and I would pick this [ __ ]
up and just throw it back I'll go like
full Rhino test
[Laughter]
that reminds me of the guy that did
stand up he had a guitar or something
like that and then he got so angry and
he just [ __ ] started like smashing it
or he threw it right no something heck
someone nothing ran the stage or
something and he [ __ ] hit him with
the guitar and then the crowd turns on
him like and they're like he got it
coming right folks and in some ways like
now
yeah
dude
boom right now what venue it's like a
lot of stand-up guys do it it's uh I
think it's on Sunset it has like
glittery gold sequins and there's always
some [ __ ] going down at this time that's
the place where Mike Tyson was a show
some dude pulled a gun out oh yeah
that's the dude there's another comic
his name's uh I think uh something
Mitchell yeah tall white skinny white
dude little some dude rushed him and
like yeah there's always [ __ ] cracking
off there it's like Sunset it's like a
rooftop in Hollywood yeah okay the [ __ ]
is it careful if you go there oh I'm
never gonna do that I'm good yeah don't
go there it looks like like [ __ ] pops
off all the time there have you ever
done that show no no I haven't but I see
people still do it and I'm like what the
[ __ ] are these foot like or is that like
you gotta earn your stripes you gotta go
to like where you might die well not
just Comics I'll just do whatever you
know like stage times like a stage time
stage they're like heckling off the bat
there like anyone's footage that you see
there is just here like yelling the
whole time is that like the theme of
that venue Dick's Last Resort but the
opposite Showtime at the Apollo kind of
situation where it's like ingrained to
the audience to boo at you or something
but yeah like I said pull out guns I
said pull out guns that sounds a little
different there was a time when we we
did a dance show in Oakland at a club
and uh these people threw glass and then
the glass shattered on the dance floor
in the middle of our show and then you
had a chance to prove a hardcore Quest
Crew yeah and then you did his head
thing boom with the [ __ ] hit oh man
that'd be so hard because I we
finished the show that happened like we
still had like three minutes left in the
set and so we were going and the whole
time I'm just looking at the ground to
make sure I don't get the glass [ __ ] I
would have stopped yeah and then the
promoter was like oh sorry that happens
a lot here I was like the [ __ ] what
though it happens a lot and the apathy
of that damn I think it just like way in
the back like there's just like some
people just [ __ ] around her they're
drunk and they're just like oh
something's going on over there let's
just throw [ __ ] at it that's pretty bad
it's a very like okay I guess that
happens that never happened to you in
any shows where someone threw some [ __ ]
on stage
panties
mostly panties that's his thing we threw
our own pennies at the at the audience
your own panties okay well we did the
show wait what wait how does that work
we've done a show where we put on like
panties on like inside and so there was
a part of the show where we pulled it
out and then we threw them at the
audience are you wearing panties right
now yeah
no Ken's talking like a free ball right
now yeah yeah he's like this time we
wore panties because we thought it was
funny that oh you know usually people
would throw their panties on stage
you're like let's do the opposite he
flipped it off it was disgusting
I will I will say there was a definitive
moment where I learned uh as a dancer
and performer to always just wear black
underwear
for my dumb ass was out of competition
this is like 2007 or so six or something
like that it's like ultimate brawl yeah
I'm supposed to run out in the middle of
the number and just hit a [ __ ] freeze
right just on like a fan you know just
one of those [ __ ] freezes and choreo
show and [ __ ] I ran out there and I
[ __ ] hit this Nike or something it
rips the [ __ ] out of my pants in the
middle and I happen to be wearing red
[ __ ] boxers yeah you weren't for no
reason right and then the funny thing is
I'm supposed to hit this frizz and then
drop right into the choreography in the
center and I'm sitting there in the
center just
there's no swag at all there's there's
just the Consciousness I can't wait
until these eight counts are done
because I think my dick's out and after
that never again it's only even in
rehearsals where I was just like hey
black underwear but that's when all the
panties started coming on stage that's
when Ken's panties
I wasn't even like why does this have
his phone number on it that's funny
because that's that happens a lot I was
when I was last time I was judging World
of Dance when you judge you have to have
a mic on you and you have to give
constant commentary during people's
shows so that once they get their score
they get to listen to everything you
thought this dude who's like front and
center and it's kind of awkward because
this is like their theme not that all
most themes are like this their theme
was like Passion of the Christ that's a
good theme so it was like very this guy
was Jesus
but Passion of the crisis specifically
like the Mel Gibson movie right like the
one where the well the Mel Gibson Bible
Yeah well yeah so then the dude the guy
who's playing Jesus does like a leap and
then it split it's his pants and he's
just doing and then the whole time I'm
doing commentary I was trying not to
[ __ ] mention and I'm like bro
everybody saw that but it's all good
[Laughter]
how would you disrupt his pants in this
part of the Bible didn't remember that
part and it's like at the end when it's
very like it's supposed to be like
really dramatic and stuff so they won
right no they didn't win you have
commentated on him like if you saw
Anthony perform come out do one freeze
dude if I had panties with my number on
I'd throw a toucan I would totally like
smoke them if they yeah that happened
that'd be hilarious but I didn't know
this guy or that team so I was like oh
damn like you can't make fun of them
yeah because it's it's of all the sets
to have that happen during a Jesus
themed set that's hilarious
I was like I would have been like look I
know this is what Jesus said so I uh
it's really hard for me to like laugh
and make fun of it but I gotta say you
just ripped your pants and that kind of
took away a lot of the whole passion
part for me and they were good too they
were like they were really good you
should have worn black where next time
wear black underwear what's the most
like hostile people have been to you
guys at a comedy show
has anyone ever been like outwardly
hostile I've had a fight break out while
I was on that's a good story because of
you but not because of me no this one's
but it was why I was like and actually I
was bombing before too like I was doing
nothing oh so this is a good fight so it
was like it actually helped my set
so I'm on stage in Ventura
uh and I'm kind of bombing and I don't
know where I just heard somebody yell
out that's my mama and then a [ __ ]
like this I heard a punch like that and
I was like what the [ __ ] and I turned
around and these two dudes are squared
up and they're kind of swinging at each
other and then this older like the the
older Mexican dude with the guy that
cracked the original guy I heard I hear
him yell Pera which means [ __ ] in
Spanish right he's like he starts
choking this lady oh and my homie was
there and he just we no one knows the
context of the situation my homie Jose
sees that and he just sees some dude
choking a lady and he sucks that dude so
now my boy and this four are getting
down I'm on stage like what the [ __ ] is
going on are you like in spider you're
like oh [ __ ] this could be good content
yeah good left hook
I wish I had that composer but I did I
was just like shocked like what the f
like what does the show continue like
what the [ __ ] happens now little by
little they Usher the people out the
cops come or whatever people sit back
down uh we find out that that guy the
lady was cheating on her husband with
that dude she was with at the show the
guy knew came with his daughter who was
like in her 20s or something she yelled
out that's my mama
husband cracks cheater dude they start
squaring up that's what went down who
was choking out who the husband was
choking his wife Oh yay she was cheap
she was cheating but like you can't
choke your wife
that's an at-home activity
that's behind closed doors no no I knew
it was coming from both your mouths too
I just bought his lead so we like I got
him to all sit down it was weird but
then I started just kind of making fun
of the whole situation and then the show
was great and they're like another 10
minutes and I was like I'm really glad
those fools got down because like I was
sucking ass and everyone was like yeah
you were sucking ass and now we're
having a good time was it Jose the guy
that punched the uh the dad yeah was he
wasn't he on the show he was a headliner
so my boy the guy cracked him he got on
stage after me and he [ __ ] smashed
for like an hour and it was like wow you
just had the other dude blood on his
nose and he's like sorry if I hit
anybody here
I was just trying to defend that lady
that's pretty good that's [ __ ] what
yeah I can't top that story
nothing like that would happen so moving
forward you guys are gonna prepare any
um rebuttals for physical heckling he
said he's gonna go malice at the palace
I don't think he's trying to prepare
[ __ ] who knows that still counts as a
preparation yeah yeah I've been training
I've been doing this all time I just
don't tennis balls at you yeah in the
dream scenario someone throws something
I catch it yeah you know like that's the
dream but I doubt that would ever happen
let's just be like
you're really good at that
[Music]
foreign